welcome back to CBS this morning it's
that time on this Friday to bring you
some of the stories that we call talk to
the table 20 Europe first all right
Laurie yeah we want to share with each
other and we everyone at home everybody
okay so I'm sharing something that was a
mainstay of my childhood or something I
remember from my on TV in my house
growing up and it's gonna be no more the
runway is closed I'm talking about the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show used to
be televised it is now officially
canceled the lingerie brand held its
first Fashion Show nearly a quarter
century ago and it began televising them
back in 2001
yesterday the parent company said it's
evolving the marketing plan that's their
explanation for all this but the bigger
picture is that this comes in the face
of declining sales at the lingerie chain
and also plummeting TV ratings for this
fashion show and criticism that what it
really does is it objectifies women so
the reason I wanted to talk about this
is cuz I think I think it signals that
it's not that long ago it was a ok in
mainstream America to have to fire women
and it's really not anymore that's a
marker of change it does seem to be
outdated but I like how you said we used
to watch this growing up in my house so
was it you and your friends you know
we're flipping through there it is
primetime Gayle
so is it new and Patrick and Neil and
Bob we had a log is a different thing
that was more of a private sever okay